papier papier dürfen blinder und ich ein
haustier haben
dürfen kinder und ich ein haustier haben
ach na
haustiere machen viel arbeit und wenn du
keine lust mehr darauf hast muss ich
mich um das tier kümmern
ach nein haustiere machen viel arbeit
und wenn du keine lust mehr darauf hast
muss ich mich um das tier kümmern
dann frage ich eben mami
do
mami
das gibt es nicht
bekommen wir ein haustier
ach das ist keine gute idee
deine schwester ist noch klein ein
haustier ist zu gefährlich
[Musik]
ach das ist keine gute idee
deine schwester ist noch klein ein
haustier ist zu gefährlich
jetzt hole deine jacke oma kommt gleich
und geht mit euch spazieren
oma kaufst du uns ein haustier
kann ich nicht entscheiden
du musst mami und papi fragen
das kann ich nicht entscheiden
schau mal dort ist opa
komm wir spielen etwas
opa blinder und ich hätten so gern ein
haustier
haustier kein problem
morgen habe ich zeit dann gehen wir in
die tierhandlung
kein problem morgen habe ich zeit dann
gehen wir in die tierhandlung
li na china
ich möchte auch ein huhn dann haben wir
jeden tag frische eier
wenn du ein huhn hast brauchst du auch
einen hahn
hähne krähen sehr laut sie wecken dich
schon um fünf uhr
wenn du ein huhn hast brauchst du auch
einen hahn
hähne krähen sehr laut sie wecken dich
schon um fünf uhr
schau mal opa
hinten sind pferde
schau mal opa dort hinten sind pferde
unscharfe gibt es auch
und schafe gibt es auch
ein noch besseres haustier als ein pferd
oder ein scharf wäre aber eine kuh
oder ein scharf wäre aber eine kuh so
könnten wir jeden morgen frische milch
trinken ich liebe mich
ein noch besseres haustier als ein pferd
oder ein scharf wäre aber eine kuh so
könnten wir jeden morgen frische milch
trinken ich liebe mich
eine kuh braucht eine große wiese du
kannst sie nicht in der wohnung halten
eine kuh braucht eine große wiese
du kannst sie nicht in der wohnung
halten
komm jetzt gehen wir in die tierhandlung
guten tag guten tag
wir suchen ein haustier für meine
enkelin
die uns eines empfehlen
wir suchen ein haustier für meine
enkelin können sie uns eines empfehlen
hier haben wir zum beispiel sehr süße
katzen
ja eine katze ist süß aber sie benutzt
immer den garten als toilette
mit einem hund er ist der beste freund
des menschen
hunde brauchen viel bewegung du musst
auch bei regen mit dem hund spazieren
gehen
hunde brauchen viel bewegung du musst
auch bei regen mit dem hund spazieren
gehen
unsere schildkröten sind auch sehr
beliebt
eine schildkröte kann über 100 jahre alt
werden
du musst dich dein leben lang um sie
kümmern
eine schildkröte kann über 100 jahre alt
werden
du musst dich dein leben lang um sie
kümmern
oder möchtest du einen vogel haben vögel
singen sehr schön
papi ist allergisch gegen vögel dann
muss er immer niesen
dann empfehle ich dir ein kaninchen
du weißt doch dass onkel willi bald
viele kaninchen hat du kannst sie immer
besuchen und streicheln
du weißt doch dass onkel willi bald
viele kaninchen hat du kannst sie immer
besuchen und streicheln
eine kleine maus wäre auch ein gutes
haustier
[Musik]
aber oma hat doch angst vor mäusen
dann hätten wir noch fische
ein fisch ist doch langweilig du kannst
nichts mit ihm machen
wir sind zu hause wir sind zu hause
europa hat haustiere für blinder und
mich gekauft
ich habe einen bären bekommen
und blinder haben wir einen flauschigen
hasen mitgebracht
was wie ein haustier hattest du als kind
was für ein haustier hattest du als kind
schreibt es in die kommentare schreib es
in die kommentare
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video